washington d.c is on edge this morning
after that friday attack on the u.s
capitol a capitol police officer was
killed and another
injured after a man rammed his car into
them at a security barricade
the attack raises new questions about
balancing security on capitol hill with
the need to keep the area open to
visitors and our jeff begays
is outside the capitol this morning with
an answer to the question that is ever
changing what does it look like these
days jeff good morning to you what do
you see
well tony it's back to business as usual
here the capitol is secure this morning
and you can see that behind me but after
friday's attack
the capitol police union wants congress
to step up security as fast as it
can and the question is will it happen
because after friday's attack there is
another situation here where capitol
police officers
are reeling
it is very surreal jason laforest is a
childhood friend of capitol police
officer william evans known as billy
who was killed friday when a blue sedan
plowed into him and another officer near
the capitol
evans a 41 year old father of two had
worked as a capitol police officer for
18
years he loved to meet the people that
came to
the u.s capitol and to serve the
lawmakers
many of whom he knew quite well the
other officer
injured in the attack ken shaver was
released from the hospital saturday
police shot and killed the attacker
25-year-old noah green
after he emerged from the vehicle with a
knife retired lieutenant general
russell honore who is leading a security
review of the capitol following the
january 6 insurrection
said the building has become a greater
target whether he's personally motivated
or dominated by some ideology
at the end of the day 24 7 365
the capitol police have to be ready to
protect their capital but
lawmakers are grappling with how to deal
with capital security while keeping the
building accessible to the public
security measures put in place after
january 6 have been scaled back
the number of national guard troops has
been reduced and the outermost layer of
fencing removed
senator roy blunt says the rest of the
fencing should come down
i think it'd be a mistake for fencing to
be a permanent part
of the capitol the idea that what
happens next at the capitol will be what
happened
last is almost certain
not to be the case
in a statement obtained by the
washington post greene's family said
that he suffered from depression and
potential
mental illness the investigation
continues into the attack meanwhile
the capitol police force is back on the
beat though their numbers are
down and there's even talk among some of
the younger
police officers of transferring out to
other agencies
tony i hate to hear that jeff thank you
very much